THIS IS AN ABUSE OF POWER AND
WILL BE EXPOSED.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA JOINS US NOW.
SENATOR, YOU HAVE PROMISED I
WANT TO GO TO THIS LISA PAGE, A
LOT OF CREDIT TO CONGRESSMAN
COLLINS IN GEORGIA.
LAST WEEK GOT THE OR TESTIMONY.
THIS WEEK WE GOT THE PAGE.
WE HAVE ALL OF THAT, 302, GANG
OF EIGHT AND THE FISA WARRANT
THEMSELVES.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS SIMPLE.
DO WE HAVE TO BASED ON WHAT LISA
PAGE SAID WE NOW HAVE TO GO BACK
TO HILLARY CLINTON IF, IN FACT,
THE DOJ RANK THAT FROM THE
GET-GO?
>> THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS I THINK
THE PUBLIC DESERVES AN ANSWER T
TO.
DID THEY SHORT-CIRCUIT THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THEY WANTED HER TO WIN
AND THEY KNEW THAT IF THEY
CHARGED HER, SHE MIGHT LOSE?
DID THEY START THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION AGAINST TRUMP AS
AN INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE HE
DID WIN?
THOSE ARE THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT
I WILL TRY TO GET YOU ANSWERS T
TO.
>> Sean: WEARS MICHAEL
HOROWITZ?
JOHN UBER.
>> THREE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT THIS.
HORWITZ IS GOING TO LOOK AT THE
FISA ABUSE, DID THE GEODE -- DOJ
GET A WARRANT AGAINST AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN, CARTER PAGE?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE THE U.S.
ATTORNEY ACTING AS A
QUASI-MUELLER WHEN IT COMES TO
ALL THINGS DOJ FBI.
I THINK WE NEED A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO LOOK AT THE POTENTIAL
CRIMES BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THE FBI REGARDING THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION AND
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
AGAINST TRUMP EARLY ON.
THE POINT IS THE CONGRESS, ME,
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
HOUSE, WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
MOBILE FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THEY TRIED TO INVOKE THE 25TH
AMENDMENT TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT DOWN?
DID THEY GET A WARRANT AGAINST
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN USING
INFORMATION THEY KNOW WAS
FLAWED?
DID THEY TAINT THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THEY WERE
AFRAID THAT IF THEY INDICTED HER
SHE WOULD LOSE AN ELECTION THEY
WANTED HER TO WIN.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET ANSWERS TO
THAT THE BEST I CAN GIVE THEM TO
YOU.
>> Sean: SENATOR THIS IS
BROUGHT TO AN EVEN HIGHER LEVEL
BUT WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY.
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA
LYNCH'S OFFICE.
DO WE NEED HER TEXTS, OR EMAILS?
DOES SHE NEED TO BE PUT UNDER
OATH AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT
INFORMATION DID SHE GIVE TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
WANTED OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN DID
HE KNOW IT AS TO ALL OF THIS?
>> HERE'S THE QUESTION OF GOD.
WHY WOULD YOU DECIDE NOT TO
CHARGE THEM BEFORE YOU THEN TALK
TO HER?
THE POINT IS IT SEEMS TO ME THEY
WERE GOING TO MAKE SURE HE
DIDN'T GO TOO FAR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE UNDER
LORETTA LYNCH WAS NEVER GOING TO
LET THIS EMAIL INVESTIGATION GO
TOO FAR.
BEFORE THEY EVEN TALKED TO HER
APPARENTLY THEY DECIDED NOT TO
CHARGE HER AND WHEN THEY DID
TALK TO HER THEY TALK TO HER
WITHOUT BEING UNDER OATH.
THEY GAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
IMMUNITY IN THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION FOR NO GOOD
REASON.
SO HERE'S WHAT I THINK HAPPEN.
I THINK THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS
SHORT-CIRCUITED BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT WANT TO COMPROMISE HER
ABILITY TO WIN THE ELECTION.
THEY HATED TRUMP SCOTS, THEY
STARTED THE BEGINNING OF THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION BEFORE HE
WON AS AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
CASE HE DID WIN.
>> Sean: HERE'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM.
RELEASING THE FISA, 302, GANG OF
EIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T SIGNED OFF.
I GUESS --
I HOPE HE DOES.
HERE'S THE INTERESTING PART.
IN BRUCE OHR'S TESTIMONY LAST
WEEK WE THOUGHT WE KNEW NOW WE
KNOW.
BRUCE OHR SAID HE WARNED
EVERYBODY IN AUGUST OF 2016.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
IT'S TAINT.
NOBODY HAS VERIFIED IT OR
CORROBORATED IT.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATES
DONALD TRUMP AND HAS AN AGENDA
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE -- IF
ANYONE SAID THEY VERIFIED IT, WE
KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE BECAUSE CHRIS
STEELE SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW IF IT
STEELE SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW IF IW
STEELE SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW IF IS
TRUE HIMSELF.
THEY COULDN'T HAVE VERIFIED IT
BUT THEY USED IT FOR FISA
WARRANTS.
>> IT GOES DEEPER THAN THAT.
BRUCE OHR IS TELLING THE HEAD OF
THE INVESTIGATION McCABE AND
OTHERS YOU CAN'T RELY ON THIS
DOSSIER BECAUSE THE GUY WHO
CREATED IT HATES TRUMP.
HE'S GOT A POLITICAL AGENDA,
RIGHT?
SO WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE, THEY
ASKED FOR A WARRANT ON FOUR
DIFFERENT OCCASIONS AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
McCABE SAID WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER WE WOULD HAVE NEVER
GOTTEN A WARRANT.
McCABE SAID THAT BUT IT GETS
WORSE.
AFTER TRUMP WINS, COMBING GIVES
THEM A COPY OF THE DOSSIER
SAYING I WANT YOU TO KNOW THIS
IS OUT THERE.
WE CAN VERIFY ANY OF IT BUT I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
IT'S THE SAME DOCUMENT THEY GAVE
TO THE COURT UNDER OATH.
>> Sean: WAIT, SO COMEY SIGNED
OFF ON THE DOSSIER ON THE
WARRANT IN OCTOBER 2016.
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP WAS SWORN IN
IN JANUARY OF 2017.
SALACIOUS BUT UNVERIFIED.
JAMES COMEY.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
>> HOW COULD THAT BE?
>> Sean: BECAUSE THEY WERE